[Music]
let's go to alyssa in fargo north dakota
that was my far going indian accent and
it was dreadful i apologize alyssa
i've heard words
[Laughter]
yes
yes
um i just love finding out i'm not the
worst of things i don't have to be great
as long as you know somebody in your
mind that's worse that makes me happy so
what's up alyssa how can i help
um okay so basically
my husband and i we've been married for
like 10 11 days
and
hold on hold on 10 or 11 days
yeah
wow okay cool
do we already have problems
not with him he's perfect well i mean
he's fine but gross no he's not yuck
you've only been married ten days
okay
all right he's perfect i love him good
for you
all right
so what's the deal so
i'm already like stressing out about you
know like
holidays two families last year we did
like both sides it was awful for us
um they still didn't weren't pleased
with how everything was set up
but more yeah
so why are you what you're you're day 10
why are you stressing about this
so my husband says i'm a catastrophizer
hold on he says this are you
um
i tend to overthink
a lot
that's such an undersell so you're a
catastrophizer
what's your favorite what's your
favorite catastrophe you've thought of
over the last 18 months
let's just get into this i love
catastrophizers oh god i don't know um
he believed me we paid all this money
for a wedding it wouldn't happen
um so when when he actually showed up
and put the ring on did you exhale like
all right sweet dodge dodge that one
um
well no because then there's like so
many other things that could go wrong
okay so
let's just get to the actual reason you
called
you are 10 days into your new marriage
and you've described him as perfect and
wonderful and so lovely
so you won right he's a good guy you
married well
right yes the and it's not even
you know it's not even winter yet
there's already 100 inches of snow on
the ground in fargo i'm assuming
yeah basically all right basically 101.
so y'all are sitting in the deep snow
together in love 10 days in and you look
over and you see him and snowflakes are
gathering on his
eyelashes and
yeah you've got one hand on his shoulder
just rubbing his back it's so good and
then you think
just a few short months
disaster we've got thanksgiving and
christmas and what's gonna happen and
then your body races to
fight that problem or to flee that
problem
oh you're so great okay so
what did you screw up last year
um well we went to both sides
that was ridiculous what else did you do
come on alyssa i know
what else happened um we only
well basically
his mom wasn't pleased that we could
only stay there for like five hours by
the time ridiculous what kind of
daughter-in-law are you gonna be alyssa
what else happened
um well actually that was mostly it my
mom seems to understand it a little bit
more which is surprising so
you're my favorite person i've talked to
in a long time so oh thank you i want to
distill this catastrophe down
so ah
you stayed for five hours and his mom
said i wish you'd stayed longer
what else did she do did she like let
the air out of your tires did as you
were pulling away did she lean into your
ear and say you've ruined my life and i
hate the fact that you're in my family
did she say that
no his mom is super sweet we get along
real great what did she do that was a
disaster
his mom is
non-confrontational at all um are you
usually yes i am
um
she's super easy going so when she like
freaked out at him over the phone and
this is all for pam
that we would only be able to stay for
so long
it was kind of like okay is this what
we're gonna be dealing with every year
when we decide to just go to my family i
mean
that type of thing yeah and i think part
of my stress comes from like how my
husband
doesn't like
handle letting people down very well and
i'm kind of just like well it is what it
is
yes
um and so you have a an avoider and a
catastrophizer all in the same
house
and
when an avoider is married to a
catastrophizer what the catastrophizer
always feels is that we are about to
drive off a cliff
and the avoider is like it's cool
there'll be a road there'll just be a
road
and the catastrophizer is like there's
no road there's no road there's no road
and then usually there is a road or
there's not but there's not even a fall
and everyone just it's a lot of spinning
up and chaos for nothing
is that fair
yeah that sounds pretty accurate have
you ever told him
i don't like that you won't address this
head-on with your mom she almost has
been dating for a while this can't be a
surprise
right um
i don't know if i've ever said it very
clearly i think i just get annoyed with
him yeah there you go because yeah you
want him to
uh read your mind and let say to your
his mom exactly what you would say to
her if it was your mom but he won't and
then you just stay quiet and you know
where that all leads right
right to resentment and then you just
get super angry all the time
and then he gets angry that you're angry
and you all don't know why each other
wasn't just doing what and then we end
up in
the catastrophe you were so scared of is
a self-fulfilling prophecy
so you ready for my little uh
simple foolproof plan here
sure
do you know what it's gonna be
is it going to be the emails
like emailing this is what we're doing
or oh you can that's what i would do
that's what i do that's what i i was
going to say i do do but i don't want to
say that that's what we do in my house
but um
do you not want to do the email are you
scared of it
i just don't think it'll go over well it
probably won't because here's why your
husband hasn't had this conversation yet
so y'all aren't at email land yet
what you need to do is sit down your
husband and say
we're going to head this off at the pass
i'm not going to
be nervous or
i'm not going to want to avoid
holidays for the rest of our life
thanksgiving christmas halloween those
things are too precious they're too
they're they're too important to
communities and neighborhoods into
family units we're not going to avoid
that and so this year already we're
going to put a stake in the ground and
say this is what we're going to do so
you all have that conversation have you
had that conversation that this year
we're going to go we're going to go to
thanksgiving this year and christmas on
that year and we're going to alternate
every year whatever it's going to be
have you all had that conversation yet
yeah we kind of have i've told him what
i think would be best he kind of is just
like i don't want to talk about the
holidays
yeah so we need to talk about the
holidays
yeah and if he doesn't want to talk
about the holidays you need to be very
clear with him about letting him know
this is stressing you out
the lack of clarity on what we're doing
more importantly
i'm i'm your new wife and whether i want
to or not whether it's wise or not i
don't want your mom
to
not like me right now
as lame as that sounds i don't want that
so
i want to get some clarity on the
holiday season before we enter enter
into it i want to get clarity on our
calendar i want to get clarity about
who's buying what gifts for who and how
let's just get all that down
and i think being real clear you say he
doesn't want to talk about it but you
also said you're not very clear with him
i think letting him know here's going to
be these are going to be the important
uh big rocks for me
and i want these to be important big
rocks for us and i want to dream about
what is thanksgiving going to look like
and christmas going to look like and
then let's be honest with all of our
family members reverse engineering that
and at some point yes you'll probably
get to the email world or
he can just have a clear conversation
with his mom and my hope is he will not
be a coward about that but will tell his
mom hey mom here's what we're doing for
the holidays not i hope it's okay and
here's what we were thinking about
here's what we are doing me and my
new wife my little new family this is
what we're going to do
and mom's going to bang her head up
against that boundary and then you'll
have to hold firm and then mom will know
oh cool if i want to be in my kid's life
because they're adults just like i raise
them
then i'm going to be a part of
their holidays not the other way around
is that fair
yeah and by the way expect her to be
have her be sad because she has a
picture of what
her married son's life is going to look
like and it's probably gonna involve a
lot of her
and it's gonna be hard for her to
realize that's not how that works
and so she'll kick and scream and act
like a child you can't control that
you can just know ah she loves her son
she loves me and she had a picture of
how this was going to go and we made it
different so ta-da
and yeah you know i've said this a lot
the earlier you can work through life
where you love your mother-in-law you
respect her but she doesn't get a vote
in your decisions the easier and more
more um the better your relationship
will be with her and the lighter you'll
walk through life
she doesn't get a vote
right well it's 10 times easier for me
to get along with her than my mother or
so
your mom
that's a whole other call you struggle
with your mom too
i mean that's like a whole other call
it's typical mother-daughter stuff ah
so
it's hard for parents to let their kids
go be married
and especially i've seen this with
mother-daughter relationships she
doesn't want you to experience some of
the things she experienced as a
young
wife
and
that's your life
and so those boundaries are so so
important you sound like you knew the
answer and you don't want to do it what
are you hesitant about
well
maybe part of it is like i need
to know if we're just being like if i'm
just being a baby because we don't want
to go to both sides
why would you hear that like it's your
holiday we're young we don't have kids
it's your holiday you can
you can do whatever you want
you just gotta be honest about it
if you are unclear and kind of wavering
other people will backfill that with
their stories and so if you wait till
november 15th to say
oh we're still kind of deciding what
then your mother-in-law or your mom is
gonna create thanksgiving pictures with
y'all in them
so if you're not gonna go be clear way
up front
be clear way up front
if you don't to go just say
we are newlyweds and we're going to do
our own thing this year
it's harder when you have kids because
then you think well i don't want to keep
my grandkids from their grandparents
want them to have a relationship if
you're going to skip out on stuff now is
the time to do it
we're gonna go to
we're in fargo north dakota we're going
to florida that's what we want to do for
christmas we're just going to go buy
ourselves to the beach
and um we will send cards
and we get to do that because it's our
life and we're grown-ups ta-da
and
getting to the place where you're again
respectful treat people dignity but
you're not apologetic for what you want
to do
your life
you and your husband's life y'all
co-created together but there is a
desperate need for clarity in your home
desperate need for you to be honest with
him about how you feel let him be honest
with you about how he feels and then
y'all just co-create this thing together
and then whether that's a phone call
clear phone call
or emails to family members whatever
that looks like man let that go and then
go have a fun thanksgiving look forward
to your holidays don't dread them don't
dread them
have the hard conversations and go get
them thank you for the call listen you
rule talk to you soon
i actually want to know how it all goes
so let's know how thanksgiving goes call
me back because that would be a fun show
that's james we're going to do that show
the um
holidays got off the rails show we need
to put the bookmark that one because
that'll just be fun or we had the
boundaries conversation and it was a
disaster that'll be fun uh show too all
right we'll be right back on the doctor
john delicious oh wait what if we do
like a three-way call where we get the
couple and the in-laws oh my god and the
other in-laws on the phone and just hash
it all out in the air we got people in
the lobby thumbs up in that yes we're
going to do a hash out live on the air
and i'll be referee and kelly will just
come in and be like you all need to shut
your mouth this would be so fun i'm in
100 i mean if you want your family to
have this conversation live on the air
with me as a referee and kelly and james
as referee spectators and with pom-poms
and throwing stuff at people
shoot kelly an email at
john delaney.com
ask is that what it is
yeah that'd be so good i can't wait